einer von mehr als 260.000 Wohnungslosen
hierzulande Daniel Z mehr als 260.000
Geschichten ließen sich erzählen wie
jemand sein Zuhause verlor dann ersetzt
geht so in Berlin Wedding zieht der 1984
in eine Parterrewohnung sehr billig und
bald sehr baufällig weil der Vermieter
das Haus vernachlässigt kürzt deine Zeit
die Miete immer weiter
Gerichtsverhandlung Niederlage 2019 muss
heraus nach 35 Jahren
wie eine halbe Leben und weil die
vermisse ja es ist hier die ganze
Umgebung es ist es es Ernstes soziale
Umfeld was ich hier hatte
ist extrem ist einfach extrem ist kann
man gar nicht ausdrücken das ist
eigentlich ja sein ganzes Leben geht
kaputt und jetzt vor allen Dingen drei
Jahre in dem Wohnheim meine Sachen sind
eingelagert die kommen nicht an meine
Bücher ran ich komme an nichts mehr dran
los so für mich es fehlt alles
nur ganz selten schafft es dann jetzt
noch in seinen altes Viertel trifft im
kieztreff Sozialarbeiter die ihn von
früher kennen und erzählt wie er heute
lebt im Übergangswohnheim
Wohnheim es hat nichts mit wohnen zu tun
es ist wirklich ein als ein Zimmer was
ich dort habe ist unter acht
Quadratmeter glaube 7,6 oder so und
jeder hat dann eine Krise jeder hat
seinen Stress und man hat dann ein
Probleme gerade wenn Toiletten sind die
Duschen sind es gibt wirklich Leute die
einfach damit nicht umgehen können das
heißt also die hinterlassen ist komplett
dreckig wir kennen die
Erfahrungsberichte aus den Wohnheim wer
einmal im Wohnheim kommt der bleibt
erstmal auf lange Zeit im Wohnheim die
überwiegende Mehrheit bleibt zwei oder
drei Jahre im Wohnheim und es ist eine
Perspektive die ist aus unserer Sicht
einfach unzumutbar trostlos für die
Betroffenen teuer für die Gesellschaft
die solche Zustände bezahlt
wie viel das schon mal werden kann
erfahren wir in einem Obdachlosen
Treffen in Berlin Charlottenburg hier
treffen wir einen Mann der unerkannt
bleiben will
er berichtet hier seit Jahren von teils
verwahrlosten Unterkünften sein jetziges
kleines Zimmer kostet monatlich
2.400 und 80 Euro bezahlt vom Jobcenter
warum das fast 2500 Euro kosten soll ist
für mich nicht nachvollziehbar es gibt
kein Sozialdienst vor Ort ich glaube
zwar dass es auch ein extrem Beispiel
ist aber es geht immer mehr an diese
Richtung also die Preise für die
Wohnheime steigen immer weiter und es
gibt halt einfach sobald man das
mitkriegt auch Anbieter die versuchen
sich da auch daran zu bereichern an der
an der Not der Leute
die Eindrücke von seinen vorherigen
Wohnunterkünften wirken alles andere als
wohnlich enge Unterkünfte oft von
Schimmel und Ungeziefer befallen
verwahrlost leider keine Ausnahme so
Claudia Engelmann vom Deutschen Institut
für Menschenrechte
nicht immer aber in vielen Fällen sind
die Zustände katastrophalen Menschen
unwürdig in den Unterkünften die
Menschen Männer Frauen Kinder die werden
dort krank sie werden vermutlich keine
Arbeit mehr nachgehen können aus der
Notlösung würde so also oft ein
Dauerzustand das sind neben der
menschlichen Tragödie natürlich auch
enorme Folgekosten für den Staat und
hier muss dringend angesetzt werden es
braucht kurzfristig verpflichtende
Mindeststandards für die
notunterbringung wo festgelegt ist wie
kurzfristig einen menschenwürdiges Leben
in den Notunterkünften aussehen kann im
Februar 2023 bilanzieren alle Parteien
im Deutschen Bundestag dieser Zustand
ist beschämend Obdach und
Wohnungslosigkeit ist in Deutschland
kein Rand Phänomen mehr als eine viertel
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland haben
kein eigenes Dach über den Kopf das ist
ein Zustand den wir in einem reichen
Land wie Deutschland so nicht hinnehmen
können gerade jetzt in den Wintermonaten
sehen wir wie wichtig die Unterstützung
Wohnungslose und Obdachloser Menschen
ist es braucht bezahlbaren Wohnraum das
heißt eine Priorisierung des sozialen
wohnungsraums zuerst eine Wohnung und
dann Hilfe in sämtlichen Bereichen des
Lebens
unterstützen
gute Vorsätze umgesetzt aber finden Sie
sich europaweit bislang nur hier im
finnischen Helsinki erfroren in den 80er
Jahren viele Obdachlose auf den Straßen
ein Schock der die Regierung radikal
Umsteuern ließ hin zu mehr sozialem
Wohnungsbau heute pilgert die
europäische Politik nach Helsinki auch
Bundes-
galwitz besucht hier menschen die im
Leben schwer strauchelten und dennoch
würdevoll wohnen so wie der einstige
Rennfahrer und Autoverkäufer heiki kako
der geiles erzählt wie er mit drei
Freunden und einer Geschäftsidee heftig
gegen die Wanduhr
anfangs war es schwer als ich mein
Vermögen verloren habe
aber zum Glück habe ich das besser
geschafft als der damalige Jurist
der hatte auch alles verloren und der
hat sich dann das Leben genommen
[Musik]
eine Wohnung samt Betreuung für Menschen
wie Heike kako das rechnen Sie uns hier
vor koste jährlich 15.000 € weniger als
ihn auf der Straße sich selbst zu
überlassen
die Zahlen kommen daher dass Menschen
die auf der Straße leben oder in
Notunterkünften untergebracht sind eine
Vielzahl von Notdiensten in Anspruch
nehmen müssen die sehr teuer sind die
Gesundheitsdienste Polizeidienste und
die Wohlfahrt wenn die Menschen eine
eigene Wohnung mit der richtigen
Unterstützung haben brauchen Sie diese
Dienste nicht in Anspruch zu nehmen
wohnen ist ein Grundrecht für jeden und
natürlich spart das so Geld 40 Jahre hat
Finnland auf sozialen Wohnungsbau und
Wohnraum für alle gesetzt in Deutschland
wurden dagegen Sozialwohnungen
vernachlässigt oder verkauft auch unter
spd-regierungen
man muss die SPD ein bisschen
selbstkritisch überlegen was sie mit den
sozialen Wohnungsbau angestellt hat also
den Fehler haben alle zusammen gemacht
aber wir haben auch gesehen wenn man 20
Jahre nicht in sozialen Wohnungsbau
investiert wir kommen jetzt von drei
Millionen Sozialwohnungen runter auf
eine Million dann braucht es natürlich
politischen Willen über viele viele
Jahre damit wir wieder zur Situation
davor hinkommen
400.000 Wohnungen könnten jährlich
gebaut werden meinte die Ministerin noch
im vergangenen Jahr hunderttausend davon
sollten als Sozialwohnung auch
Obdachlosen eine Perspektive bieten
dieses Ziel rückt angesichts hoher
Inflation und explodierender Baupreise
in sehr weite Ferne
Daniel setzt Aussicht auf eine eigene
Wohnung sie wird immer düsterer